Esta es una de las tantas playas de la
ciudad de Odessa una de las principales
ciudades de Ucrania que ha tenido estas
playas cerradas desde el comienzo de la
invasión a gran escala en febrero del
2022 las autoridades estaban planeando
reabrirlas este pasado 15 de junio
estaban haciendo todas las indicaciones
para que las población pudiera venir a
lugares específicos y disfrutar no
solamente del mar sino de algunas partes
de las costas habían tratado de limpiar
de las minas con las cuales han venido
llegando hasta aquí sin embargo todos
estos planes han quedado destruidos
después del derrumbe y la explosión de
la presa de cajobca en el río nieper
aquí todavía encontramos algunas
personas Pero según las autoridades
vienen en contra de la ley no deberían
estar en estas playas por dos motivos
primero porque podrían tener Minas
dentro del agua además la contaminación
que no solamente está allí sino que
también ha venido a la arena los últimos
estudios de los últimos días han
demostrado que en el agua hay salmonela
y también infecciones renales pero no
solamente eso sino que la presión del
río también ha bajado decenas y decenas
de minas personales que se han instalado
También muchas más en todas estas partes
del mar Negro y también ha traído
cadáveres especialmente de animales lo
que ha hecho que el agua tenga mayores
infecciones Así que ellos le han pedido
a la población de que se abstenga de
venir a estos lugares lo que es muy
difícil cuando suben las temperaturas a
28 grados centígrados o 29 como nos
encontramos Pero lo que sí está
permitido por ejemplo es que haya
lugares como el que está atrás algunos
restaurantes acerca de la playa donde
pueden venir a comer y tomarse unas
cervezas sin embargo pues como estamos
viendo hoy hay quienes aprovechan y
disfrutan un poco del buen tiempo pero
han dicho los ecologistas que esto
tendrá consecuencias gravísimas para el
medio ambiente no solamente las próximas
semanas y meses sino en lo que vienen
los próximos años